uh alex i believe you've got the list of
attendees and any apologies uh we've
received apologies from councillor rigby
and he sent uh councillor honesty in his
place
thank you very much uh next item is the
minutes of the last employment committee
has anybody got any issues or questions
they want to raise about those minutes
now in that case we'll move on have we
received any questions from the public
no questions have been received thank
you alex
the next item is is there any urgent
business uh
to put before the committee
no uh the next item is employment
committee updates
is that you
would be angela councillor bennett oh
thank you sarah
hello good afternoon everyone it's
lovely to see you again
and so just to give you some highlights
from um
our employment information so as you
will see from the report
attached to the minutes and agenda
we continue to see a steady decline in
our sickness absence cases across
and the council and you will see a page
six that in terms of our available
workforce
that remains at a healthy level above 96
which is really really positive in the
circumstances
in terms of our health safety and
well-being
and before i continue um on this page i
will start
by um offering a note of thanks to our
health and safety team who have been
absolutely exceptional
and in the last six months and provided
great support
and to colleagues and managers across
the council
and there have been significant activity
in this space and we continue to support
our schools our colleagues and land
managers
and as we deal with the ongoing
challenges relating to covid
we continue to work through our
workforce reintegration plans we do have
a
subcommittee that is co-chaired by diane
geary and angela beadsworth
and we are looking at our workforce
reintegration plans
aligned to our estate strategy to
understand
and what we will need to support the
workforce of the future
as it stands at the moment we are
working towards the 20
occupancy rate within our buildings but
we expect that that will increase to 30
and 40
over the coming weeks and up to the end
of october
i'm pleased to report that we have had
great
and feedback from our colleagues and we
are managing the social distancing
aspects of
workforce reintegration and really well
and colleagues are respectful of the
fact that we do have a one-way
system and we do operate in a an
identification of desk
space and protocol which colleagues have
adapted to
and are working really well in terms of
our engagement and organisational
development
agenda we have continued to run our epic
manager program our development
programme during this time
all be officially but but successfully
and we have had some great feedback
in relation to that training i'm also
pleased to inform the committee
that our engagement agenda in terms of
let's talk and our vehicle leaders
sessions have continued
we held a number of sessions um
throughout the summer and i'm pleased to
say that particularly for the staff
engagement sessions we were
oversubscribed
and had to put some additional sessions
on which is always good
and we have a number of sessions planned
throughout september october and
november and we'll continue to do so
and probably until the end of the year
when we will consider
what our engagement strategy will look
like and going into
the new year in relation to our policy
development a lot of our attention has
been
on supporting our line managers heads of
service and colleagues
and in planning workforce reintegration
and also as well to support colleagues
who are working from home
and who have caring responsibilities we
will continue
to work with with our colleagues and
also as well specialists in this area so
we have spent a lot of time with
northwest employers
and sharing best practice across mgm and
more broadly
to understand how we can offer that
ongoing support
and to colleagues who are balancing
working from home
potentially having children at home or
potentially having caring
responsibilities which
which is no mean feat and we will
continue
to to develop a robust policies in that
space
and i will conclude my update on the
employment position by just advising
the committee um case management
employment relations case management
it is now running as normal i'm pleased
to say so
we are clearing our backlog in relation
to
case management and i'm also pleased to
inform that some of our cases are now
being heard in person
and supported by and counselors on this
course so thank you very much
and we are also in the process of
reviewing
and the resource hub which as you know
we set off in response to
um to the covered pandemic and how we
managed our workforce during that time
we are looking to adapt and enhance that
offer
for future services so that we have a
more agile way
of redeploying colleagues and also
to support it in our attraction agenda
as as we move through
in the coming months so at that stage
councillor
pause and take any questions that the
committee may have on this particular
report
thank you for the update sarah does
anybody have any questions for sarah or
any comments
yeah councillor thompson
thanks for that sarah um have we had any
staff
testing positive for the virus
recently and have our protocols
held up about self-isolating and
what's the response been thanks
okay so um counselor thompson it's a
really good and timely question because
yes we have
and um i am pleased to say that our our
response was extremely effective and we
have a number of colleagues also
self-isolating at the moment
so we've had to my knowledge but i will
um stand corrected by them who's
probably slightly closer to it
and to my knowledge we've had three
instances where we've had a colleague
who has
tested positive and then subsequently
we've had to make some
um adaptations quick adaptations and in
the workplace
and but our colleagues have responded
brilliantly and
we have a situation at the moment where
we have five colleagues who are now
working from home
and but the great thing is because of
the effort that we put in
at the initial stage they literally pick
themselves up and taking themselves to
work from home they're not suffering
from the symptoms of of covid so yes it
does seem to be standing off but as i
said
and bed may want to add to that there's
anything you may want to add
um again just to say that um the
significant work that health and safety
have
put in place with their risk assessments
with their guidance
and that whole package that surrounded
um
working from home and the mobilization
of the i.t
as sarah said yes it's it's been very
easy
for us as a service and also for
managers to literally lift that
and support people really really well to
enable them where they possibly
can do to work from home and continue to
do their role but albeit in a slightly
different way
thank you councillor
can i just ask uh about the guidance on
returning
from travel abroad um
clearly you know the advice changes from
um one minute to the next in terms of uh
government guidance um
has there been many who who've been
caught up in
in this and um and how has
how have you been handling that i i do
know
that there's various measures that you
talked about in the report but i just
wonder how it how it's actually working
in practice and thank you councillor
for that question and again another time
the question uh we
have yes we have had a number of
colleagues so initially
um when the announcement came around
spain
we had a number of colleagues who were
actually in spain at that time
so we made some very quick decisions
around how we would support those
colleagues when they returned to the uk
and how we would support them and to
isolate and then return to work
you absolutely write the guidance um is
changeable
and so i i i'm rightly so if if
there's any risk then we do need to be
mindful of that so we are
very aware of keeping track of countries
that are
in and out of in potential and
quarantine
restrictions and also as well we're
being really open to for example now
we've had a colleague
who has retained from a country that
is not quarantining what has suggested
that they would come home for a week to
self-isolate
and just be sure that they've not picked
anything up in the airport etc
and we're supportive of that because
it's sensible so anything that makes
sense and has a logical approach to it
then we
are trying to apply a sensing reason
to to our approach i can't
recall a case whereby we've not been
able to support a colleague i'll stand
corrected
um if my colleagues would like to come
in but actually i think
um our approach should be one of a
reasonableness
[Music]
okay can i just follow up on sorry
counselor actually go ahead
yeah all it was really uh
in the report it does say that um
you know uh our workforce should should
actually contact their manager before
they
travel which seems very sensible and at
least
they are aware um you know that
if something does happen abroad they
know
what the consequences may be in terms of
return back to work so
i i just wonder whether that is being
done
uh by by all managers
so i i am not aware and i'll turn to
that again i am not aware of
any issues that have arisen where a
manager has a
approach to to say that colleague has
not followed that guidance from me for
we found ourselves
in a sticky situation and i think and
one thing i will say
about how pretty much everybody has
approved this situation
is we are listening to the guidance in
the me
and i'm trying to enact that guidance so
colleagues
are approaching this sense of caution i
think as well what we have no system
and anecdotally what is being fed back
is a lot of
our employees and i guess people in
general
are cautious about traveling abroad at
the moment so therefore i think
and we are seeing the benefits of that
in relation to the impact of
of the quarantine restrictions when when
when colleagues are traveling
so i'll just bring that in for a moment
because i wouldn't want to
give you false information counselor
aston silver is there anything that i'm
not aware of
that you may want to report at this
stage
i've i've had no data and so
from that i i'm not aware of any issues
there's been nothing that's been
reported to me or has been in discussion
with the trade unions either during this
time
and i think sarah is absolutely spot on
i think people are very cautious about
traveling abroad per se
and even those i'm aware of even
yesterday with conversations i had with
individuals
and they had booked a holiday um even
following on from lockdown
but because of the changes um they
cancelled that holiday
and didn't go and i do think our staff
are are very
aware of what's going on and i think
that is supported by the significant
amount of communications that are issued
to all of our workforce
um you know three times a week on the
manager's brief and on the employee
briefs as well which continue
um and that keeps them completely
up-to-date they're very transparent and
i think they're very helpful
but as i say i'm not i'm not aware of
any queries
that have come back or any situations
that fall into that
um you know that category does that
answer your question counselor attend
thank you
sorry i i just wonder whether all staff
do understand that they
they are supposed to uh you know talk to
their managers
like line managers before they actually
go abroad
and then they would understand you know
what what
the guidance is in terms of um you know
the workforce what actually happens
when they return um you know if they're
unfortunate enough to be in that
situation
so i think it is that initial talking to
manager prior to them going and
then understanding completely what our
guidance is
i think it's just as simple as that
really because that's that's what's in
the report
and i just wonder whether that is
actually working effectively that that's
all as simple as that
okay i i'll take that away counselor
afton and we'll do
some further investigation but just to
give you some reassurance
we've not done this as a one a one-hit
wonder we are reinforcing the message
and so hopefully it has landed but what
we will do is some analysis around
and try and gather some case studies of
where those conversations have happened
so that we can assess the effectiveness
of the message
thank you thank you sarah councillor
boys did you have a question
yes sorry and this is probably will be a
really really really silly question
in the event that uh one of our
employees and we already
mentioned three actually test positive
and therefore they are self-isolating
that's with or without
symptoms are they then deemed to be on
sick leave
um no that's that's straightforward
so we don't record it for the purposes
of sickness absence monitoring
but yes they are sick they all they are
unfit
to attend work but in terms of so
they're on fit they're not working so
there's no issues about
employers liability in terms of them
doing work
when they shouldn't be because they're
not at work
that's the point i'm making yeah thank
you very much thank you
thank you councillor boys any further
questions for sarah or beverly on this
item
thank you the next item is agency spend
uh 2019 2020.
okay i'm gonna take this one if that's
okay yeah so hi good afternoon
um i'm going to cover so i was going to
propose to cover off both so we've got
the annual agent
bend report and then we've also got the
quarter one of this financial year so
i'm going to go through give a summary
both of them and then take questions if
that's
agreeable thank you okay so the annual
agency spend report for
2019 um it covers the full financial
year
and within there we also give a detailed
spread then break down a quarter four
being you know the last period in that
year
um so the overview is that spend in 2019
was 2.7 million
um and that was an increase on the
previous year 20 2018-19 which was 2
million so there was a
700k increase between the years which
you know is a significant increase
um but to reiterate as we always do you
know this is all funded from within
service budgets
so instead of having substantive staff
the spenders you know being diverted
through to agency
um with some good areas of good news
um so we did have reductions between the
two years and some of our directorate so
in four of them we saw that so we
saw that in governance and strategy
finance and systems
the people directorate and the place
directorate so some of these saw
significant spend and reductions
actually so that's really really
positive
um but as always the challenge is uh
mostly in children's services
um due to the social care and social
workers and you know and as we've
discussed in meetings previously this is
an ongoing national issue
we've got pressures locally you know
competition between authorities for
social workers and particularly in
children's services
and due to a lack of suitable candidates
through our
normal framework provider um we started
to engage with other providers and this
was back in i think it was around may
2019
um but obviously these other providers
um
attract higher rates um so that impacts
on our spends
um and if you look at the spend
throughout the quarters of the financial
year you'll see that the spend
increased incrementally in each quarter
and and that is
mostly due to the um using other
providers and their higher rates
um but you know the the ongoing issue
with being able to provide enough and
enough quality of agency workers through
are
through reads the framework provider has
necessitated that position
um so there's still lots of activity to
try and improve the position
and to try and have more of a stable
workforce
i think some of the measures will take a
bit of time to get to fruition
um so lots of work around trying to grow
staff into these roles internally um so
we buy in the level of commitment when
we're investing in our staff to become
fully qualified
and so we've got our measures include um
where possible we are encouraging our
agencies staff to take up permanent
positions we could convert them
essentially
and i think we have had some success in
that area we've got our
social work apprenticeship program
continuing um
so that's ongoing and we'll have you
know staff qualifying you know each year
and people starting each year we've got
the frontline
social worker training program which has
two units within um trafford
um and we've got we continually
encourage students who have undertaken
placements at trafford to apply for
positions
and again we've had applications which
have been shortlisted and progressed
we've also been looking at our um
recruitment
um approach for this you know niche
group of
individuals um to try and look at
different ways of attracting them
and that's ongoing obviously we're also
looking at how we train our managers in
in those services to improve um the
retention of social work staff
um and we have we've i believe we've got
14 new employees starting in social
worker roles in children's in septembers
and some of these are on the
aysc year which is the assessed and
supported year in employment you know
the first year after they're qualified
so that's encouraging
and i believe we have not engaged any
new social workers through alternative
providers since the end of july
which again is quite encouraging a
change in position
so that's the summary of the annual
report so
unless people want to jump in and move
on and talk about um quarter one of this
financial year
okay any questions
arising from the first section of the
report cancer action
thank you yeah he's just uh clearly we
have this on the agenda
um every meeting and uh
uh and you know i know that it
is it has gone up um you know quite
significantly and i've
you know not read the reasons for it and
they you know they're very justifiable
uh reasons um and
the main one is a shortage of social
workers
uh whether they're agency or um you know
working for local authorities and it's
something really
to me it's a national issue a national
problem
um and it needs to be sorted out
nationally
you know to to whatever the reason is
for people not wanting to take up the
positions of
social workers it's something that
needs to be tackled somewhere along the
line
because we constantly you know come back
to this
and and i think we're working really
really hard to try to
solve it ourselves locally
and across gm um but but
you know we we still stuck with the
problem
um and you know it is my view that some
somewhere along the line it has to be
national
government that actually you know helps
to sort this out
thank you councillor action counselor
boys did you have a question
yeah yeah it's a quick again just going
back they're going to come back in the
smaller directorates actually this one
will be
before with the directorate reductions
is it expected that those reductions
will be
maintained in the current year and going
forward
yes i will what i when i go through
quarter one i'll show you the position
and
again that you know position has
continued so there's minimal spending
quarter one from those the other
directorates
which shows we are getting uh you know a
handle on agency spend in the other
areas but it's children's
particularly and some adults obviously
as well that is the key focus really to
try and um
you know see what we can do to to you
know to develop a more stable workforce
internally without that need for
reliance
nice to meet you councillor holden did
you have a question
yes please just uh i won't say a quick
question everyone says that it never is
um frontline training during lockdown
bothers me
with the talk you met you mentioned the
need for
and the action of recruiting new
social workers to work with our children
how are we actually managing the
training
of someone who's got to work in a
face-to-face role
during the restrictions of lockdown
okay angela do you want to come in on
that or do you want me to take it
[Music]
um i think in answer to the question um
we've been you know if we brought any
social workers in during the lockdown
position
um then the social workers will have
undergone um you know
sort of a significant induction process
and we talked we've
we talked previously around what that
induction process is
um i think they will then have adopted
the approach that would would have been
in place during that sort of lockdown
position and if that didn't involve
obviously working face to face with
children
and they would have adopted those same
principles
so i accept i i suppose you know it i
think the reality is it is probably a
harder
um situation obviously to come into that
sort of frontline
role during this you know pandemic
situation
but you know i think the assurance is is
there that we still need to continue
to obviously to bring new people into
the organization and to wrap around
a suite of support to you know so that
we can get them
um onboarded as quickly as possible up
to speed you know with all of the
organizational
requirements that we need to to enable
them to be good officers and so that
when
they are in a position whereby their
their role um
changes then then they're in that
position where they can step up for the
role as
quickly as possible so
i don't know whether that's answered
your question or not counselor holden
but i think i just wanted to give you
that sort of reassurance that all of the
you know the sort of the safeguarding
all of the protocols that that needed to
be in place to ensure kind of a safe
onboarding
of of social workers and you know in
terms of the roles that they play
in terms of maintaining kind of the safe
environment
but that role to take place then that
you know there is that assurance that
that was
that that is in place
thank you angela don't underestimate or
please don't think that we don't
appreciate
just how difficult the situation is
um but i just wanted to listen briefly
as and if you've done it expertly
to understand just how we are
trying to cope with a situation that's
verging on the impossible
thank you thank you
does anybody else have any questions on
this item
before kate moves on to the position
2021
first quarter
no go ahead okay yep so agency spend
quarter one which is april to june
and the total spend was 891 664
pounds which was a decrease on quarter
four
of the previous year of about 20 k so
that's positive so considering the
resourcing pressures
we start potentially having caring
issues self-isolating etcetera that
that's positive that we maintain that
position i think
and because it could have gone the other
way with all the pressures um
also to detail the fact that of the
total spend 76
was on social workers so it really you
know is the majority
um we've talked about the issues with
children's that's continued
um and actually if you start to break it
down and look at the spend on social
workers as a percentage of
children's services it's even more
um based around social workers than it
was in the previous quarter so it's
around 1992
of the children's services spend is on
social workers so it means they reduce
spend
in other areas and and it's just in one
main area really
um however we've talked about some of
the measures in the previous report to
improve the position and obviously we've
now got our new corporate director for
children's services
who is looking at it and has a massive
focus on how we can improve recruitment
and retention
looking at our package looking at the
culture in the service
so lots of work ongoing at the moment um
looking at other areas adult spend has
reduced so again they seem to
be you know minimizing their spend and
it's positive that the other
three other directorates have minimal or
no spend
at all so the position has improved in
other areas of the council and that's
continued
to be the case and that was all from
that any questions
thanks kate i think it's still vital
that we pursue exit forms to understand
why staff actually leave because
that's a major part of retention
understanding why people feel the need
to move on
so i hope that will continue with that
work
yeah just to mention to update you on
that i know that one of the officers one
of the senior social workers might be a
team leader or service manager
and within children she's absolutely
been tasked at looking at dealing with
the ex
interviews for social workers in the
area so they can really get a handle on
that and have those
in-depth conversations to get that
information through to really try
and make change it's excellent thank you
kate
i think we're now going to move on to
the next item which is the new and
social
hours allowance policy is that you
angela
here again me again okay so okay so this
is around additions to our unsocial
allowances payment structure
um so currently we have in place of
framework um for recompensing staff who
work during unsocial hours periods
which is normally evenings nights
weekends and bank holidays
and the way we approach that is it's
basically based on the frequency
frequency of hours and worked in
different on social sort of periods
and it's also waited for more on social
periods so for example you'd get more
pay if you were at night
as opposed to evenings um so the
payments are
a percentage uplift of an individual's
basic pay
dependent on the level of commitment or
their shift pattern if you like during
the unsocial hours
periods or bondings um so there are
different
bandings um and the minimum payment is
three percent
and it goes up to a maximum of 20
dependent on your level of commitment
um we've experienced a situation in one
of our services which has led to us
looking at
um the structure and thinking that we
need to rise to that to cover some
different scenarios
for lower levels of commitment in
unsocial hours
so the service in question is some staff
who work in
our mental health um well mental health
social workers
basically this is a service where they
work alongside nhs colleagues
um in greater manchester mental health
and there's a requirement for them to
work several weekends a year
um so it's not a regular commitment and
generally to date within the council
certain services have regular weekend
working
and some have very ad hoc regular week
sorry ad hoc weekend working
but we haven't really had any who've had
to have been in a position where they've
been required to do
several weekends a year um which is why
we've not really had to look at this
before
um so basically with our current
framework the commitment that they're
undertaking is not enough for the lowest
bonding of three percent
um but it is more than sort of ad hoc um
so we recognized we needed to do
something you know to recompense fairly
so um these staff have been receiving
annual payments on a temporary basis
while we've been seeking
the most appropriate solution um
and we've come concluded that we should
have two um new percentage uplifts at
the bottom of
the bandings if you like to be added to
our existing framework because we don't
want to
we don't want to do something different
we want it all to fit together and to be
appropriate and fair
um and we've suggested that we have a
one percent uplift
um where three percent of an individual
shifts are worked at
um weekends and bank holidays and a two
percent uplift where
six percent of shifts were our weekends
and bank holidays
and basically it's fair internally
because if you look at the level of
commitment for the other bandings it's
proportionate
we've also looked externally considered
um the commitment and the pay that
nhs individuals employees get to working
alongside our staff
and i think that's that's quite
difficult because obviously they're on
different terms and conditions different
organization but
day to day they're working with somebody
and they might be having conversations
about
you know what they're getting for that
so we've looked at that as well
and i think there is some parity you
know we can't match our terms and
conditions but you know it feels
fair i think um and so that that's the
proposed solution
um and also to mention there are a
couple of other services who i think
will be needing to work certain number
of weekends a year
so i think we may need these bandings
for
a couple of other services and there may
well be more in future
um so that's why it feels the good you
know the right thing to do now
um and it will meet a couple of aims
really
um so we've had conversations with the
unions um who are supportive
of this as a solution um and if we get
agreement then we'd start to consult
with the staff
in this service i think there may have
been some early sort of sensitive you
know conversations but we'd um you know
go out formally and have those
discussions
you know and see if that is a you know
the right thing to do and their
support there okay and that's it any
questions
kate how many staff do you envisage will
be impacted by this
oh i don't actually no one's off my off
the top of my head um
oh it might be in the region but don't
quote me of 20 or so
sorry i don't know if it's on my head
but they these are stuff that are doing
quite a vital role
that we want to retain and this seems a
fairer way
of uh keeping them in line with the
colleagues they work within other
services
does anybody have any questions or
comments on this item
yeah can i speak certainly thank you
councillor
yeah yeah i i am supportive of the
uh proposals uh i think it is trying to
develop a fair system really um
well what am i right in assuming that
uh the proposal is cost neutral
yeah the staff had been receiving a
one-off annual payment and and i think
at the time it may have been calculated
on this basis that there won't be an
additional cost to the services
the other option was you know them
looking at their service provision and
is there any other way they can provide
that and we looked at different options
around can we get other
additional staffing to do that but
because it's
weekends a year per employee commitment
and it's just the weekends it
we couldn't have resourced it that way
so it has to be existing staff and
obviously they've got the vital skills
to provide that cover
at weekends thanks kate
anybody else got any comments no
questions
aquila go ahead can i just ask is there
any significant numbers of staff i know
you said there's 20
it might affect but is there any group
who are going to be negatively impacted
on where they're going to
end up with a reduction in what their
salary is due to these changes
no this shouldn't be because they
they've been receiving an annual payment
so the difference will be
it will be factored in in terms of their
monthly pay they will get
um you know it'll be generated through
the system so they'll get a regular
payment rather than a once-a-year
payment and what will have to happen as
well is um
once we agree then the services will
have to monitor the rotors
to make sure that the level of
commitment that they are doing has been
shared equally by the different staff
who have to undertake this
um because i think you know there's a
risk that it will end up being
some staff go on the road to more often
at the weekend and others do left but
they'll all be receiving
the same percentage uplift so that will
have to be managed and we will you know
work with the service
to make sure that's the case and they
reviewed wrote us
i was going to ask about that how it was
going to work because i was just
thinking about your finance department
with the nightmare of
each month trying to figure out for each
individuals what percentage they should
get
no no no the services do that and then
they have to review the rotor and if the
rotor changes and the level of
commitment
increases or decreases then they would
then change the percentage and they just
put it through the eye trench system and
that's quite straightforward that aspect
okay
thank you kade anybody else but anything
on this item
if i may i just wanted to come in to
support what um
kate was saying you know in advance of
these proposals
um being put to you today there has been
significant conversations with the
service in terms of what do they have at
the moment what do they need
is it a reaction to what's been
happening over the last five years or
are we now
making sure that this is a robust
solution for what we anticipate in the
future as well
um and obviously it's been made very
very clear to managers about that rota
system to make sure that it is equitable
and fair
and to be honest with you i'm sure the
staff will be the first ones to say hang
on a minute you know i
i'm i'm doing more than my fair share
please sort it out but yes the managers
are very clear
and there was that robust discussion and
exploration of
all sorts of options before um arriving
at this one which is the
the fairest the most transparent and the
most appropriate one
thank you for that clarification beverly
i've been notified that
uh council of boys would like to come
back on the previous item do you want to
put your question counselor boys
uh yeah it's just on the uh the spend
there just looking at the the governance
directorate in in the last quarter of
1920 and the first quarter of 2021
just seems a significant increase in
costs related to
legal and solicitor matters like is can
you just give us a little bit of
background as to why
that has hiked up so much in those two
quarters as a proportion of the spend
thank you thank you for the boys
i mean i can start to take that question
and anyone can support after i think
um it's it's a really difficult area
recruiting um legal professionals
because obviously you're comparing them
against them
you know the markets and local
authorities obviously you know we're
bound by our pay structures
um whereas a legal professional may be
able to attract
you know higher salaries um externally
um so i think they've had issues and i
think it you know it
i might be correcting if i'm wrong but
it may also be issues around the
response to covert because obviously
their workload in that area i think may
have increased i don't know if beverage
or sarah would
comment on any particular issues
i'm happy sorry can i come in so i are
you basically saying that
we at those points we were
basically short of head count or short
of
capacity and therefore the only way to
deal with it was
agency consultancy which is clearly
going to cost us
whatever you know probably twice twice
the
you know in the private sector as it
were twice the public
sector rate uh for equivalent
skills to be able to deal with it so and
it just it's uh
is it where where are we in the second
quarter this year
we are able to recruit people are we
still
in this difficult situation
come in there and just to assist
um i think it's fair to say that after
qualified social workers
the the next area where we have the most
significant
trouble in recruiting and retaining is
in
um the solicitors so in the legal space
um
i think these service have been running
with a number of vacancies for a while
um
and then the the sheer increase in
workload
has has meant that we've had to explore
or the services has to explore
agency provision and i think that's
fundamentally the reasons for the
increase
in the costs okay right thank you very
much thank you
thank you chairman
the next item on the agenda is the
quarterly report on
exemptions to the sickness policy
have we any to report
is that angela i think it's fair but i
think she's struggling to get you
back do you want to take it beth i it's
okay so in quarter one april to june
this year we received
six exception requests um
but one of sorry two of those were
relating to the same person so we had
two requests from the same
person within that same period um
so we had no requests
from children's resource and strategy
governance and finance
and the requests that we've received are
in the adults um
and children's space
all of them were approved so there were
six applications in total
and all of them were approved
thank you does anybody have any
questions for beverly on this item
no then i think we should move on
alex yes
uh we're going to move to the exclusion
resolution
is that a separate meeting now uh yes
once the resolution has been passed i'll
stop the live recording and we'll go
into the closed section is everybody
content to move on to the exclusion
resolution
that looks like uh yes alex thank you
yeah
yeah i'll move the exclusion resolution
thank you
thank you